so the other day i had a conversation
with my two boys about sending them to
boarding school that there's some
message there but you should hear about
the reaction ten and eight-year-old kids
are looking at me saying you're gonna
send us to boarding school i thought you
loved us but wait before you say i'm a
terrible parent wait for the story by
the way if the story makes sense give it
a thumbs up and subscribe to the channel
so let me get right into it so i'm the
other day i'm upstairs
and i'm doing my thing in the closet and
then all of a sudden my son shows up
daddy you won't believe what chico did
and
hey distilling stop being a snitch why
do you tell daddy everything why are you
pestering why are you doing this so they
come upstairs okay and they're going out
and they when they fight they have some
real fights i said what's going on okay
what now
i can't live with this guy
i can't
he's driving me insane
i'm like oh really i can't i can't do it
no more how about you i can't he just
it's too much it's too much okay so what
just happened right now daddy you want
to know what tico did what did tikko do
tico did you know what's the thing like
you spit on it you do the ear thing i
don't know what americans call it it's a
what do you call it what is it
wet willy is what they're doing right so
so he did a wet willy on me i'm like
wait man i'm trying to hold myself
because i don't want to laugh because if
i laugh i'm undermining the important
issue to him
so i said okay guys listen this is
getting too much every time there's
problems you guys come up to and this is
every day and it's getting a lot of
pressure on your mom on me on melva and
papa we got to figure something out i
have a great idea they said what's that
grab a seat
so they sit down they're they're looking
at me like ready for this incredible
idea and i'm gonna come up with i'm
gonna say listen
are you are you done with this i'm done
with it i can't do it anymore are you
done with it i'm also dumb i can't i
can't deal with them anymore i just
can't live with them anymore i said you
can't live with them anymore no
i said so here's what i got to do it's
going to be very expensive but i'm
willing to make the
investment into it this is what's that i
said there's these two
great boarding schools one isn't seattle
one is in new york by the way i have no
clue if there's a great boarding school
in seattle and new york i'm just telling
them there's these two great boarding
schools one's in seattle one in new york
i have a solution on how to fix this
it's gonna cost me about a hundred
thousand dollars a year but i want to
propose it to you guys what's that daddy
what if dylan i send you to the boarding
school in seattle
and chico i sent you to the boarding
school in new york you guys don't see
each other but once a year no stress
you don't have to bother with these
fights
it's over with you don't deal with it
you don't see each other once a year i
fly you guys out for christmas you'll be
with me mommy family for a week and
tonight you go back to your boarding
school you don't have to deal with all
these pestering snitching stuff it's
done so what are we doing by the way
it's very expensive what should we do
about it
so
so i'm listening to these guys look how
creative my oldest son is my oldest son
is
daddy i don't think it's wise i said
what do you mean he says why would you
send both of us just send him and save
money on it and keep me home i'm like
this guy he's so good with that he says
you don't have to send both just send
dylan i'll stay home and we'll save that
money i said
no it's not going to be that well
because if i want to i'm going to send
both of you guys no i don't want that i
said do you want to go to the boarding
so i don't want to go to the boarding do
you want to go to i don't want to go to
the boarding school wait
i thought you guys can't deal with each
other anymore no it's not like that it's
just we don't want us and why don't you
go to boarding school we don't want to
go
anyways five minutes they're thinking
about boarding school and they're
thinking about what it would look like i
said okay if you don't want to do this
we got to figure out a solution because
you can't come to me with a prom every
time by the way some of you guys are
saying what's what's this all about if
you're running a company and everybody
constantly comes to you by bitching and
complaining about everything they can't
handle it together you're not a leader
you're somebody that's crippling
everybody right so watch what happened
here
i said so
if that's the case and you guys want to
stay here you guys got to figure out a
way to resolve issues together without
coming up to me mommy and daddy every
time screaming about each other so what
are we going to do
so what do you not like that he does
well i don't like the fact that every
time i do something he has to come and
snitch to you daddy so i don't like the
fact that you're pestering half the time
okay so how do we solve this how about
we break down levels of snitching when
is it snitching and when is it you have
to tell daddy and mommy because
somebody's hurting themselves so daddy
if if if one of us does drugs that's not
snitching you have to tell mommy and
daddy okay cool what else
if one of us has got a girlfriend that's
doing bad things and teaching us bad
things and taking us to bad areas i
think it's important for mommy and daddy
to know okay how about everything else i
don't know if we do some small stuff
here we got to keep it ourselves okay
cool so you guys going to resolve it
together yes
pestering listen you got to stop
pestering because i don't like this
anyways they're having this full-blown
conversation together for 20 minutes and
i'm just sitting there listening to
these guys
three hours later on downstairs i come
home i see dylan running up to me and
dylan says daddy you won't believe i
said i'm sorry
okay
tico you and i have to go have a
conversation together
and tico looks at me he's like
okay let's go so you guys want to go to
the board no no no no no we'll handle it
they go to the board and you hear i'm
listening to them so you did this i
didn't like this well what are you going
to change about i'm going to do this
okay are we good we're good shake hands
and i run off real quick so they don't
see me now they're doing that so what
happened here's the point
when people come to me in my office and
they complain about each other here's
the first thing i ask i'll say have you
had the conversation with him yet no why
not
i just haven't are you expecting me to
solve the problem that you're having
with that other individual well no i
just think you need to know
uh is this a problem you can get over i
can't then you got to bring it up do i
need to schedule the meeting between the
two of you guys or can you have the
conversation oh no no no i'll have the
conversation they leave nine out of 10
times they never have the conversation
i'll follow up a day later two days
later did you have the conversation no
not yet week have you had to come no not
yet then here's what i'll do many many
times i'll do this
i'll set up the meeting and i'll tell
them i want to meet with you at 2
o'clock and i'll tell him i want to meet
with you at 2 o'clock they both have a
two o'clock meeting with me and they
don't know about they come in
and i say how you doing good oh uh am i
i'm sorry
no no you're fine please grab a seat but
but i thought it's just no no you also
can grab a seat okay you guys are good
yeah you guys are good okay i think you
guys got to talk to each other i'm going
to step outside
i thought this meeting was with you no
this is actually meeting between the two
of you guys let me explain to you why
every time you guys have issues it comes
to me
and i'm done with it you guys got to
learn how to resolve issues together
when you're done come get me and i want
to come back in here to see how we can
resolve this issue moving forward i'll
step outside they'll come back 45
minutes let patrick can come in okay so
what's the resolution we came up with
we figured it out hug it out good okay
let's go take over the world right the
point is if you don't challenge your
peers to resolve conflicts amongst each
other and every time they come to you
you're not building leaders you're
building enablers you're not building
people that can stand up under you're
building leaners not leaders it's a big
difference and it's purely based on your
method of resolving issues with your
organization so
if this boarding school story made sense
to you give it a thumbs up and subscribe
to the channel okay so the video i want
to recommend to you is a video i did on
conflict resolution it's eight conflict
resolutions for entrepreneurs if you've
never watched it click over here to
watch it have a great day bye bye bye
bye
[Music]